for the past 24 years I have been a
firefighter in Huntington West Virginia
as firefighters my team and I are tasked
with saving lives and property from such
disasters as car wrecks house fires and
also life-threatening medical
emergencies I am a woman leading a
department in a male-dominated
profession and ten years ago I decided
to increase my medical knowledge and I
received a nursing degree that was
because it became clear that the next
big threat facing not only my city but
other cities around the country was not
the one-and-done disaster where you can
ride in like the Calvary as a
firefighter put out the fire and leave
feeling like you have made a difference
and everything is okay the next big
disaster in my city was and is the long
debilitating and lethal disaster known
as opioid addiction we now call this a
health epidemic and we have replaced the
name addiction with substance use
disorder to give you some perspective of
how significant this epidemic has become
in 2017 in my County of 95,000 people we
saw eighteen hundred and thirty-one
overdoses a hundred and eighty-three
deaths from overdose this it's the job
of my firefighters as well as other
agencies to respond to that excuse me
so watching this epidemic unfold for
several years I developed some insight
for this disaster we need to redefine
our job
a first responder we need to be more
than just the Calvary we need to do more
than just save a life we need to find
ways to real rebuild that life and it's
going to take a lot of people to do that
and that is exactly what we are trying
to do in Huntington West Virginia now
let me give you some insight as to what
we do this is what first this is what
happens when somebody overdoses imagine
you or somebody who is suffering from
the brain disorder of addiction you are
fragile
you're embarrassed you're ashamed and
you overdose maybe a friend or a family
member calls 911 and then all of a
sudden you are awakened by five or six
strangers total strangers in uniform and
they're rubbing your sternum and they're
saying wake up wake up you overdosed you
could have died now would you not be
defensive and angry because I know I
would be and on top of that those
strangers gave you a dose of naloxone
which has sent you into withdrawals or
what is better known as dope sickness
dope sickness makes you feel absolutely
horrible some say it's like the flu
times 10 nausea vomiting diarrhea body
aches so not only did we as strangers
wake you up but we also made you feel
really sick so in turn you the patient
are not going to be very kind to us and
you're going to refuse medical treatment
further medical treatment okay well then
that's going to frustrate the heck out
of us and we're going to be mad because
you're ungrateful that we just saved
your life this is not a good dynamic
here so what we are dealing with is a
brain disorder that changes your
thinking
it convinces you that you don't have a
problem so this might have been not only
the first time you've overdosed it might
have been the third fourth or fifth time
that we personally have revived you this
is not a good situation second first
responders do not receive much education
on what substance use disorder is
neither does the medical community we're
not trained how to deal with those
suffering from substance use disorder I
am trained to to put out many different
types of fires I am trained to save a
life in the moment but I am not trained
to deal with the intricate interaction
between first responders the healthcare
community social services and the wider
community that is necessary to save a
life long-term thirdly and this hits
home as a first responder I consider
myself the Calvary we want we're a
knights in shining armor we want to
swoop in do our job and leave feeling
satisfied that we've made a difference
in somebody's life but that just doesn't
happen when we're dealing with somebody
with substance use disorder we leave
feeling frustrated and useless we deal
with the same people over and over again
with no positive outcome and you know
what at some point I realized that it is
up to us as first responders and as a
community to solve this problem to find
better ways to deal with those that are
suffering so we so what I did is I
started observing more on overdoses I
started talking and listening to my
patients I wanted to know what led them
to where they are what exactly are they
experiencing what makes their situation
worse what makes their situation better
I began
with my words and paying attention to my
own actions and how it affected those of
my patients the education that I have
received and continue to receive on a
street level in Huntington has been both
eye-opening and life-changing for me so
in Huntington West Virginia we have come
together as a community and we are
changing the way that we treat those
that suffer from this horrible disease
we have started many programs and it's
making a difference I'll tell you about
just a few of those last year we started
a quick response team QRT for short the
team consists of a paramedic a police
officer somebody in the recovery
community and somebody in the faith
community as a team they go out and
visit people who have overdosed within
72 hours of that resuscitation they talk
they listen they build a rapport with
that patient and they offer them
treatment options right now about 30
percent or up to 30 percent of those
that the quick response team have
reached out to have accepted some form
of help and the wonderful thing about
this is the first responders who are
involved in this team they actually feel
like they can make a difference positive
change where there wasn't any this year
this year we opened a free-standing
specialty clinic called proact for those
suffering from substance use disorder
it's a one-stop shop if you will a
patient comes in they are immediately
assessed by somebody who's an addiction
specialist they work with them to
provide treatment options based on their
own needs individual needs this does
several things for us it gives first
responders a place to either take or
refer our patients who are no longer in
a life-threatening situation that have
refused to go to the hospital and it
also clears up the overwhelmed emergency
rooms and hospitals that we have the
third thing that I want to tell you
about is very dear to me and very
important to my team we recently started
a first responder self care program okay
more and more first responders are
experiencing compassion fatigue and PTSD
it is not uncommon for the average
firefighter in Huntington to deal with
or see up to five young deaths per month
these are their friends these are their
classmates so this much-needed program
will not only recognize their hard work
it's going to give them a voice it's
going to provide them with training that
will help deal with the stress that they
are under and it will give them more
mental health options that they
desperately need we now have yoga
classes in fire stations
[Music]
we've also provided on-duty massages
which is fabulous
and we have some off-duty programs that
we've started like cooking classes for
first responders and their significant
other in pottery classes so a couple
months ago I walked out on the apparatus
floor where my I had some firefighters
and half of them had had a massage and
the other half we're getting ready to
have a massage and I saw ten
firefighters who were bantering in a
very positive relaxed manner and I
hadn't seen that in years
and that that relaxed state is trickling
down to the community to the citizens so
a couple weeks ago I had a neighbor
overdose twenty two years old so of
course I hurried down to help my
firefighters in my neighbor and what I
witnessed was my firefighters being
supportive talking in a non-judgmental
way I watched as one of my firefighters
showed the father and another family
member how to provide rescue breaths
should this happen again and left him
with a bag valve mask positive change
positive change did I happen to mention
the two things that firefighters dislike
the most the way things are and change
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you know I recognize that there have
been drug epidemics before and I've seen
what crack can do to a community a lot
of our critics think that this new
compassionate response that that we're
doing in in Huntington is is because of
race that because the overdoses are
happening so much to the white community
and I understand that criticism because
we as a country messed up and we treated
black people poorly during the crack
epidemic we can't forget that and we
must do better but right now what I know
is people are dying and we in Huntington
deal with people suffering from
substance use disorder of every color
and every background on the streets
every day the job of a first responder
prevent unnecessary death period so
obviously I'm a stubborn firefighter and
nurse and I refuse to believe that there
isn't a way around every barrier one of
the barriers that we have dealing with
the opioid epidemic is stigma so we in
Huntington West Virginia are showing the
rest of the country that change can
happen that there is hope dealing with
this epidemic
our current overdoses are down 40%
currently our overdose deaths are down
50% this epidemic is far from over but
each and every one of us has a part to
play in this epidemic just by listening
and being kind to somebody you have the
ability to make a dent difference in
their lives thank you and God bless
[Applause]
[Music]